I've known I'm in love with you for a
while as well former bachelorette ali
fedotowsky weighs in on monday night's
episode of The Bachelor the 31 year old
reality star tip to her blog Tuesday to
show her support after been told two
women he loves them she writes quote
telling two women he loves them truly
came from a sincere place I think he's
romantic he loves love she does
elaborate saying ultimately quote he
should have done what all this other
bachelors and bachelorettes did and keep
his cute little mouth shut until the
final rose but well he didn't then
basically broke a bachelor rule each he
caught up with him after the women tell
all taping where he says he's found the
one yes when this was going on I love
two women but now I'm happily in love
with one and that's gonna stay that way
for the rest of my life The Bachelorette
alum has had a happily ever after of her
own and is expecting her first child
with fiance Kevin mano ET chatted with
her in January I feel good and I'm
excited and I'm showing now